e
oh um since this is my committee and I
can do anything I want um you guys don't
have to sit out there we're one happy
family and if you want to sit up here
that's great David you're the smartest
guy in the room of this bill feel free
to come up here if you want uh I just
find it easier than staring at a dark
cloud space back there anyways this is
the um interim study subcommittee for
House Bill
554 um Prime sponsor is David lungren
who is here today which is um great um I
wanted to begin by just reminding people
what the purpose of this bill is and why
we're here and why this is important as
many of us know there was a quote opioid
crisis um that happened um I personally
believe that it was disingenuous that
all the blame for the opioid crisis was
placed on pharmaceutical companies
because there was plenty of blame to go
around one of the faults of the Health
Care system was a failure to provide
access to multiple therapies or
alternative therapies preferably an
integrative manner um this bill has come
up several times twice through um
representative lungren and it's an
attempt to try to increase access to
therapies that we know have value um and
next question is how can we do such in a
coste effective manner that doesn't
unnecessarily burden one group over
another but in the end helps the people
that we're trying to serve so that's why
we're here today um this is our second
meeting um I handed out an agenda for
everybody and the first order of
business is for those of us that were
here before was the minutes from last
time um are there any questions about
that comments thoughts whatever I don't
remember what that what's that yeah I
know was it your it was your comment it
was my comment but I have I mean I think
it sort of says enough without another
word added so for the for the record in
the minutes um I I you're looking at the
guy that kept them and I didn't write it
up till about a month later and Bill
made probably the most astute comment a
representative Palmer sorry made the
most astute comment that will ever be
made at a legislative session and I
couldn't read my own handwriting so um
it never got documented so um I just
wanted to give a brief overview of where
we were where and where we're going but
um I think the one thing that came out
of this was that we pretty much were in
agreement that we need to move forward
um
one of the issues that was brought up
that was actually brought up in our
integrative pain committee also was
what's actually the definition of pain
which is why that's the second order of
the the um the meeting today um the
third issue that we raised was that
whatever we do needs to be evidencebased
um but also that um the evidence base
that we use is consistent with that used
for other modalities for example we
can't give certain allopathic treatments
of fair uh Free Ride merely because
they're allopathic um the the the um
level of evidence should be similar um
we should be fair to insurers um it's a
tough world right now and we should be
fair to them we need to be fair to
Consumers and uh we need to be fair to
the Health Care System um and so that's
where we are today so um as this next
are there any questions about that
thoughts comments whatever Mr chairman
yes um it's been a while since I read
the bill are those currently addressed
in the bill or that are those things
that would need to be added to a new
bill um the way so the bill that you
have in your hand is my proposal for um
this is the current bill the amended
version yeah the yes everything that's
there is in that bill we everything you
just mentioned is in here yes okay great
thanks with the yes everything's in
there with one subtle difference and
that's what we're about to talk about
right now
now um so what I did was um when we so
the third item on the agenda is to talk
about the definition of pain and um I'm
not going to burden this group with this
but when we did our integrative Pain
Care committee meeting that was the
first item that was brought up is
defining pain which then went on for a
two-day
discussion um and I don't think all of
us prefer want to be here but in the end
the version that you have right in front
of you is what we came up with um the
International Association for the study
of pain redefine this in
2020 um what's in red um on that handout
is additions that we made to their
definition um do you have that um I can
give you that one I'm sorry I put them
one Mr chairman is this the language
that appears on page four no no in the
Bly itself you mean well I'm looking no
no it's um I can get you
copy they're right uh they're right over
there
yeah y so this is the subtle difference
is what's there is not what's in the
bill what's in the bill is the historic
um International Association for
actually thank
[Applause]
you so I I just want to be sure I'm
looking at the right piece of paper it's
not that in in fact you this has a lot
that's been struck out but it's got
stuff that's left in exactly so this is
going to Super see what's in here maybe
that's the point of discussion should it
yeah I'll give you a couple minutes to
go over
that is this the one that be you brought
back on the floor a special no no yeah
actually right it does yes it was for
that that
bill but you got a good
7 Lucy hasn't hit 30
yet talking about age you haven't hit 30
yet are we on video or no is this on
video this meeting should be live stream
all right fine which means take your
microphone off again I'm not supposed to
advertise
so just as a drafting question because
I'm now working off of this which is I
think what's under
consideration are you
considering putting the clarifying Parts
into the bill or is that what's under
discussion at this point that's under
discussion I think it's kind
of just as a
background are we ready to talk about
it so um so historically if you look at
the first paragraph the uh definition of
chronic pain up till the end of the
three um eliminate the red items in that
first paragraph that's the historic
definition we've always used it's pretty
much what's in the bill um it became
apparent by 2020 that it you know for
reasons that we actually brought up at
our committee our integrative Pain Care
committee meeting that it wasn't
sufficient and so so um they
commissioned another study group to look
at that and redefine it and so that's
where the rest of that came from I mean
it's I think if you add patience
centered in three months to the
definition you probably done enough for
the legislative element of it but I'd be
happy to see what other people think
because the rest of this in my world is
like really important and what we're
doing in the integrative Pain Care
committee it's really important I don't
question I haven't encountered the word
NOS acception
before so in a nutshell pain uh exists
is there's two elements to pain there's
no susception and suffering no
susception is the actual neural process
by which a a neural vending is
stimulated and gives your brain a
sensation that something hurts and you
develop a reactive response suffering is
the element that you know that's more of
the emotional and diffuse response to
the painful stimulation and so in the
chronic pain world they're both
important and at some point actually the
suffering is more important than the no
susception but they're both important
okay I I I I would think that you know
you know as you go forward with this
bill um the definition of pain should be
more or as succinct as
possible um I think the meat of this
bill has more to do with the insurers
the providers the medical system in
general and I would argue that you know
the the the definitions that you put
down there in the bullet points may not
be
necessary uh except to understand it
better for
ourselves um
and my one of my other questions is I I
don't have a problem with patient
centered I I do wonder about why it was
necessary to change the current
definition and why the addition of the
lasting more than three months is in
there as
well for our purposes we needed to
Define for the integrative Pain Care
committee we needed to Define what group
of people we were going to Target so we
were going to Target people like when
you that level of care was probably
excessive for somebody who for Less Than
3 months so we kind of arbitrarily came
up with a 3mon definition for what we're
doing here today it's it's it's not
important okay so I mean I the patient
centered actually interestingly I think
and if you look at the minutes you're
the one who raised the patient centered
thing and I to me
that's it's it's absolutely critical
because we we're providing healthc care
based on algorithms that are lumping
everybody into one giant category and
and we're trying really hard in
healthcare to not do that um but in the
business model that's the way it's
done thank so so yeah I mean the patient
centered sort of can incorporate a lot
of these bullet points so that's nice
the only thing about the three months is
um so if we're talking about insurance
coverage then that that's kind of
important whether we put it in or not
because you if it's only two months then
maybe it's not covered if we put in
three months so I guess that's the
question is should we should there be a
time limit in the bill at all or is
that that's my question it's a good
question and the reason I would say we
don't need to put it in is because this
bill is addressing both acute and
chronic pain so the time frame really
motions I have a left sided field
neglect here I should probably be over
in that corner or
something we'll wait for
him so just just to recap um I mean what
I was about to suggest is that you have
two definitions one one being pain and
one being chronic pain which has the
durational aspect but if people are
satisfied that all we're defined with
for respect of this legislation you can
just go with the definition of pain and
not have to decide what the what the
limitations are but it it's it's easy
just to Define make the two different
definitions um it's interesting just Pat
our sponsor on the back if you look at
outcome data the most efficient way of
dealing with acute loac pain is actually
with chiropractic care and that was the
whole purpose of this bill was to try to
increase access to that as an
acupuncturist I know my treatments work
much better on acute pain than chronic
pain and that and virtually all of us
can all of us healthc care providers in
the room can say that that's that's true
and so um that's why the time element I
don't think needs to be defined here but
if we feel strongly that it should be
that's fine representative mer mer thank
you Mr chair uh during the discussion I
think one of the reasons for the three
months was trying to
find a demarcation to separate chronic
from acute and again back to the
insurance is having something in there
as a timeline to help the insurance
folks and everybody else and providers
that represent Mercy Murphy brought up
as well is where is that line from
between acute and chronic it's not
specific but we had to draw something
somewhere the other side of the coin too
when talk about patient
centered when you start talking about
pain what I began to to understand a lot
of pain is subject to the person's own
interpretation of the pain so what may
work for one patient may not work for
another one and when we get into the
issue of who should decide what works
and what doesn't work it really should
come down to the patient because it
maybe things that the patient the
studies say it doesn't work a lot of
times pain can be controlled by a
placebo it's the mental part of it and
that's what Dr McKay represent M was
talking about as well we can't forget
about the human brain and that part of
it has to be there too which is
sometimes the emotional side of it so
that's why those two things were woven
in there one was to give some sort of
diff differentiation between chronic and
acute and also be sure that we're
centered on the patient and what
they're providing to the provider and
saying what works and what doesn't work
versus somebody saying well there's no
article out there there's no science
behind it well a lot of times when
you're treating pain it doesn't always
come down to the science comes down to
the
patient but I don't think you
can I mean it's certainly true that
amongst different modalities one might
work better for a given patient but I
don't think we can ask for an insurance
company to cover something for which
evidence because the fact if one patient
says you know ground rhino horns just
makes my back pain so much better I
don't think we want to you know have
insurance compan feel that I mean if you
see what I mean yeah I I totally agree
with what you're saying R Palmer the
challenge though is that when you get
into science and trying to get into
something as
evidence-based we put sometimes so much
at so much emphasis on the evidence that
sometimes there's it seems you do drug
trials for for example we know that the
drug may work in a certain population
but it doesn't work in all the
population so therefore when you look at
and saying well the study says it works
but the patient will tell you it doesn't
work because it doesn't work in that
subpopulation so even though we have
trials and we have evidence-based it
should not be construed that we have to
rely upon it completely so that's why
I'm trying to be sure of is that even
though the science is there we have some
way for the patient's involvement and
well so it sounds to me like um one of
the things you might want to think about
is viewing the evidence base as a floor
rather than a ceiling because we do know
I mean I'm just thinking about the usual
painkillers that people buy in the drug
stores some of them work for some people
and some of them work for other people
and some of them have side effects for
some people and for other people they
don't
so and I'm not sure for purposes of the
bill you need to Define this completely
but um I think some kind of
floor of scientific evidence is
important but uh the thing that I
learned through my late husband's Cancer
Treatments was I always thought that you
know you had condition a you
administered pills C and you B and got
results C and of course that's
completely untrue it's it's far more art
it's an art and a science and and that's
why I like the patient centered
point because that's what you're looking
for is what works for this patient but
with some guard rails on it the Rhino
horn and this is where we get into the
problem is who gets to Define what the
evidence base actually is and and it's
when we did our prior authorization
Bill one of the big problems that we
found was that each insurer get is using
their own evidence base and you know
without any ability really for us as
practitioners to question what's your
evidence base why are you using it one
of them I'm going to cite my book again
sorry but one of the more CH important
chapters in that book was Miss and
realities about evidence-based medicine
and there was a study of the Cochran um
Cochran uh Cochran data collection which
is the largest collection of
evidence-based medicine in the world
it's held in Scotland and um not that
you need to know that but anyways um
what they did was they looked at 1,00
medical question questions and to find
how many do we have no facts how many
are satisfied Beyond um you know
question whatever they found out only 3%
of medical questions among the 1100 were
settled Beyond question which means that
97% of medical questions there's a
question and and so that the reality is
there are no facts and and that's where
we get back to Patient centered care and
that's to me be honest you have in maybe
inadvertently raised the most important
part of this bill um to me
personally thank you
sir one of the other things that was
discussed was if it is patient
centered instead of trying to
micromanage it is trying to find a way
if we could is give the patient a um a
bundle if you will of dollars that they
could utilize and let them at that point
in time be more in charge of how those
dollars get allocated
on their care for chronic pain and let
them sort of have more stewardship over
how those resources are being utilized
versus us at that point in time trying
to say well this works this is carbonet
because it becomes so difficult trying
to figure out what to include and what
not to include an example in
hospice they don't you in hospice you
get a certain amount of money per DM per
day but it's up to the hospice
organization to decide how to utilize
the dollars and it's up for them to
decide what works and what doesn't work
and what they want to use the money for
so that kind of breaks it apart so the
insurance industry has some sort of
obligation to the patient but at the
same time there's also some Freedom
within the patient themselves the how
those dolls get utilized between
themselves and providers and so forth so
if they want to use an aai Chi because
it works there's a limited number of
dollars that are available that helps
reduce the risk factor from the
insurance company because from a
Financial Risk at the same time gives
resources I mean that's
it thank you that's an interesting idea
the only thing the difference is that in
hospice the hospice team medical team is
working with the patient to decide so
it's not just a patient driven thing the
patient doesn't have unlimited options
of what the hospice agency is going to
pay for and um so having been a hospice
medical director for a number of years I
mean we certainly had
people I mean you know like Father Gil
taking a guy fishing was uh one of the
ways we spent some of the hospice money
I think he was actually volunteer but
um but that wasn't that wasn't a medical
treatment but it was very good for the
patient but as far as medications or
other treatments it's still got to be
ordered by a doctor so presumably the
doctor's not going to order the ground
Rhino horn um so there has to be some B
balance because because otherwise sorry
otherwise otherwise the the only other
way I would think you could do it would
be to make a list of different things
that would be covered which then gets to
be either very difficult to do in you
know a huge negotiation or um or or it's
going to be limiting in slightly
thank you I thought you were going to
speak um I you know I I don't disagree
with everything that is been said so far
and from a clinical perspective your
your thoughts that the definition of
chronic pain and particularly patient
centered approach to it is very
important to us I I understand that and
I would not disagree with any of the
bullet points though I don't believe
that they need to be included in the
bill itself per se My suggest is that
the definition of chronic pain could be
as previously stated with the addition
of pain centered because I think that
the major part of the bill that is going
to be controversial is going to be the
burden that's put upon providers and
upon insurance coverage so my my sense
going forward would be that we look at
the the what we have written down as
chronic pain and modified with patient
centered because it is patient centered
in many ways but I I and I agree with it
as being very
important but I think that we really
ought to be getting to some of the more
controversial parts of the bill that are
going to be what is mandated for
providers and for insurance coverage to
um to be included within the bill would
you keep the three months or remove it I
would remove it y perfect I because I
think simple is better and the reason I
would remove it is because I think that
pain is a very subjective thing as soon
as we start getting into more of the
detail s involved the mandates of 3
months and the time periods involved etc
etc the more uh difficult it's going to
be to be as a provider provide coverage
for that pain um so and I'm glad you
said what you said because we are
getting into the discussion of mandates
that's a big deal yeah and I mean I'm
fine with
that I totally I'm perfect with that I
I would there be some
um consideration by the committee to
include the word usually lasting more
than three
months which gives a little more
flexibility again the same thing I'm
just trying to look at it from the
insurance point of view but me some
words I actually go ahead for the
purposes of this bill didn't I
understand people to say that we don't
need a definition of chronic pain we
just need a definition of pain exactly
yes and therefore uh we don't need to do
the limits and if there's something
farther on in the bill that addresses a
chronic condition then we can look back
to that but um I speaking as the most
lay of lay people here
um anytime somebody says to me you know
lasting more than 3 months that means
that somebody's got to hurt for 90 days
before something happens and and don't
want to get into a situation where we're
um arguing about that down the road so
unless there's a reason in which case we
should Define pain and then Define
chronic pain I'd just leave it as pain
and and go forward there and then deal
with the meat of the bill which is going
to be um the thing that's going to cause
pain among our colleagues um I would I
would second that and I would say that
it was an Omission on my or yeah
Commission on my part chronic should not
have been here it should have just been
definition of pain so are we then I
missed that part sorry about that we're
deleting the word chronic in the
definition so it's just definition of
pain exactly okay thank
you
yes McDonald sorry thank you Mr chairman
yeah getting back to representative
Murphy's comment about the uh the
insurers uh I think that's a number one
hurdle in this bill from everyone I've
talked to in the house um and um I I
know at least one lobbyist is here from
I think representing insurers I think
that's one of your clients right uh so
that's that's the number one challenge I
think this bill has and and it's an
important bill and I I'd love to see it
become law but that is going to be a
major consideration in uh talking about
stakeholders talking about people who
need to be in the discussion and so
forth I think that's a probably our
biggest hurdle and our greatest priority
so are we okay with the definition as
we've as representative Murphy has
proposed and all of us actually so just
to be clear we're going to your your
suggestion is that definition of pain as
you wrote it out there we eliminate
chronic pain keep patient centered in
lasting more than three months is what
you would include in okay were you okay
with that I am do I we don't need to
make motions and things like that right
and that simply means that to go back to
the thing that looks like a bill what
we're going to do is insert the words
patient centered and the rest of it
stays exactly the same
perfect good
job who says government can't accomplish
things so um that brings us to the next
thing where we actually look at this
bill so I I I just want to reiterate
some of the background of this bill
where it came from um um this bill I
think has been proposed three or four
times now um representative maputi did
it first and then representative lungren
took up the flag um and then we had met
be well before I became a legislator um
we put to because we thought that this
bill was really important so what we did
was we took the bill because we at at
the medical society had concerns about
it but I also work with the US pain
foundation and um the woman that I work
with there um Cindy Steinberg who's not
here today um she's their legislative
representative nationally and she's also
their chair um in Massachusetts and they
had actually created a somewhat similar
Bill there um so what we did was we
looked at the bill that they had created
and we brought her across state um we
put together a work group um that
consisted of a couple docs me I'm a doc
um um Cindy and um the reason why Cindy
was important Not only was in her
legislative role but she's also a
patient with chronic pain so um and she
represents millions of people not just a
couple so um we sat down we went through
the bill um and what ended up coming up
with was of of taking a lot of what
representative lungren had created
changing it in a manner that that the
medical society could back
um be a little bit more specific about
what we were after eliminate a couple
things like there was a report in there
that um probably isn't necessary we
could go over that in detail um and then
we came up with a format that ended up
getting submitted as House Bill 303 that
then got attached to what was the
original 554 was I don't remember the
original bill number from a couple years
ago but so now we functionally have two
bills that are side by side so what I
tried to do in going through this um
with the red and the and what was struck
out what wasn't what was added um was to
try to morph them into something that's
a lot shorter simpler and we'll
hopefully accomplish what came through
in a number of our meetings
specifically um the original Bill
included a number of things like Chiang
Tai Chi Yoga that are not um provided by
licensed therapists um so the general
consensus was that whatever we de within
this bill now needs to be done by a
licensed therapist so the the the things
in there are like movement therapies
Chiropractic osteopathic um something
that might be done by a PT but it's
important to say this bill does not
include Physical Therapy um massage
therapy which is performed by licensed
providers acupuncture which is provided
by licensed providers psychologic
therapies like cognitive behavioral
therapies and things like that which are
provided by licensed therapists so we
really got way more specific on it um
and this was done as a a group it wasn't
just a me thing and what you're looking
at is actually a group effort by people
that represent pain people represent
doctors um the one missing pieces is
insures and what we've tried to do is
include you guys in this too so that we
get something hopefully that'll be nice
for
everybody so I'm still looking at at
this document in front of me um
and so is the proposal going forward
limited to the um uh wording in red
because I've got wording in Black which
sort of looks to me like it's staying in
the bill and if it is then on page five
we still have aquatic therapy yoga Quang
and
taii which are the modalities that are
less likely to be licensed profession
thanks for bringing what line on page
I'm on page five and I'm on line 10 and
11 yeah that will need to be removed
yeah okay I just I just want to make
sure we're all no thank you cuz that's
important looking at the same thing yeah
anything in red that's struck is it was
original um that's been taken out
anything that's in that's red now was
either moved from one place to another
or is new and anything in black is
original that's staying okay which which
document are we looking at oh it's the
thing that says bill number at the top
and it's 5,000 pages long so you're
going to strike lines not um not all of
line because some of the movement
therapies uh physical therapists and
chiropractors are certainly licensed
professionals um and then I'm not sure
about the ones going forward from there
but I just think you need to make a note
that somewhere there you're going to
have to start drawing lines I don't know
if I can say this out publicly but
you're a smarty pants thanks for
bringing that up and I mean it's know if
you can say it this is this is why I'm
the token attorney on this committee no
and and and I the reason why pts are not
included in this is that insurance and
physical therapy are not an issue um so
that's why we didn't include them in
this
bill well then I think I think it it
it's would you might want to discuss
where that sentence ends or if it's
included at all I'm just putting a
question mark by it if I could go back
to a comment
before about the Rhino bones or whatever
we're talking about before if it's
ordered by the
provider would that not be covered now
trying to get to with chai Chi and so
forth that the provider thinks it's
going to work to help the patient would
that not be the again
the floor we're talking about where it's
being somewhat controlled by a decision
by a certified individual that has the
license to interpret that repres and and
I'll just say that
traditionally um when we've looked at
bills like this and it has it has been
an issue back and forth and I think that
you know what you're talking about is
basically having a gatekeeper and
somebody with a license has to say yes I
think this is going to be helpful for
this patient but you still have the
issue and I think it's going to be a
very huge issue depending on who the
payor is if you are referring to
somebody who is not subject to license
or certification rules of some kind uh
you're going to run up against a huge
roadblock um I'm I'm pretty sure that
the cmc's are not going to be happy with
that for one thing and and that's a huge
amount of the coverage and this may not
cover that at all but um it just it has
traditionally been an issue going
forward repr pal well what I was going
to say is that I mean the rhino horn
that's basically like medication and so
there are going to be medications that
you'd have to go through some prior
authorization to get because of whatever
reason either because they're very
expensive or because there's no you know
evidence obviously there'd be a lot of
different
medications that would be helpful in
chronic pain and hopefully all of those
will get covered assuming there's some
rationale but that seems like a SE
separate set of stuff from this bill
which is sort of the um so if I could
add to that I mean right now if you look
at the healthcare dollar about 2third of
the healthc Care dollar and I may be
wrong but um at one point this was true
is basically out of pocket expenses for
miscellaneous other things
um you know like Rhino bones or whatever
I I I'm not putting that in the minutes
but anyway so um um you know that's just
people make their make a discretion that
they're going to conscious choice that
that's what they want to do and that's
fine um but they pay for it out of their
own pocket the question we're asking
here is like what do we expect or what
will we like insurers to cover and um
and I think some things are a bridge too
far at this point and maybe on the road
yeah you know like if we have licensed
chiong therapists and um you know they
have really a more organized educational
program and we have more evidence-based
then maybe they would be included in
this down the road but at this point
that's lacking and so um and so that's
why at this point we don't feel and this
is like a big broad group of people that
discussed this and how we came to that
conclusion I go back to the issue of the
gatekeeper mhm it sounds like the
gatekeeper is not the patient it's going
to be the insurance company and that's
my concern is that we're
now basically turning it over from the
patient even though we're saying it's
patient centered it comes back to the
it's Insurance centered so therefore I'm
trying to balance the two and saying how
do we ensure that it's truly patient
centered and not something through P
approvals and the gatekeeper really
becomes the insurance company and not
the patient and the provider and I don't
know where the line is drawn but
philosophically
that's kind of what i' like to get into
this bill is that we have a balance
between the two where that is I don't
know can I represent thank you
um so the bill that you sent to us has a
lot of what representative Weber is
referring to that has been already
deleted and the reason I mentioned that
is because if I read this bill it
becomes very succinct and becomes very
explicit as to what we're talking about
M so referencing representative
Merchant's question
I as well as a provider don't agree that
it should be the purview of the
insurance car is to basically mandate
what is covered having said that if you
look at page one of the one that you
sent out to us page one
um the patients seek treatment from mer
conditions that cause pain a certified
it should be maybe a certified
healthcare provider so again it is a
healthcare provider that is basically
certified and unlike the days of past a
lot of the education now for opad
management particularly in the last 20
years is now Incorporated in you know in
um uh provider education grant rounds
Etc but is also provided and also
there's a check in the recertification
process so if you want to back up to my
you know again as nor p in a very simple
mind and a lot of this stuff I would
basically make the provider the
gatekeeper in the sense whether it's the
orthopedist the primary care whomever it
is that it's a
certified
individual that refers to any one of the
other options available so that could be
part of a bill and it could be one that
is also Incorporated in the physician or
provider education programs that they
have available to them the second part
of that then becomes the insurer and
that is addressed again in your new copy
of this which has deleted so much but I
do have concerns and I think the
insurance carriers would also agree with
me that the insurer is then mandated to
provide a lot of what is you know uh
prescribed by the prescribing physician
or provider um but they mention in page
two you mentioned in page two and you
mentioned again in page four that each
insurer whether it goes from um on page
two
three um uh they they have to basically
submit the the insurance um um to or the
coverage to the um HHS I agree with that
that each insurer also has to supply and
produce you know again this becomes a
bit onerous on the insurers and I get
that part of it um produc and Supply
with each renewed insured issued
policy uh educational materials the
educational materials I don't have a
problem with providing providers to do
that is a different thing altogether but
is included in here as well because it
says in Roman numeral 6 they sure ensure
shall ensure an adequate number in type
of licensed professionals that may be a
bridge too far and difficult for a lot
of people to get to so what I'm looking
at here in my simple mind is what does a
gate keeper the provider is mandated to
do I don't like to legislate Health Care
delivery but on the other hand if we
have something that says they at least
should through their educational
programs mandate or they should you know
prescribe or offer as
Alternatives that'd be one thing but
then again the insurance carriers have
significant burdens that are you know
placed within this bill as well so I I
think we have to try to resolve olve
those is what I'm saying can I ask a
pragmatic question is this
recorded it's on live stream I believe
so in other words I can because you just
said a lot of good stuff and I didn't
write any of it down because I wanted to
hear it um but if I can go back and
watch a recording so that we make try
simpy this to that the mandates that we
are legislating for the healthcare
provider MH which I I would I think is
important but I think a lot of it is
covered now current
and maybe some of the the the bills that
were previously brought up did not
recognize this but there is a lot of
educational stuff that's out there and
is we all know there's providers that
basically covers the providers you know
knowledge base and also their their um
uh prescribing techniques and also
providing alternatives to care but again
I want to be sensitive to the insurance
carriers and what is mandated in there
as well um so to me this is like a
carrot and stick thing like like in the
medical profession we're being carrot
and stick that we have to use an
electronic medical record even when we
don't want to because they're cost
inefficient and they destroy private
practice so they're using that with us
to me this is I'm sorry us you guys them
thing but this is important um right now
what what I what a lot of us in in the
medical field don't understand is you
know you can get access to this drug
this in surgery that that injection
without any problem and the insurer will
cover it much of that doesn't have any
evidence base at all but they still will
cover it however we have evidence that
chiropractic helps acupuncture helps
cognitive behavioral therapy helps
massage helps we have licensed
practitioners that provide those
Services we think that they're coste
effective we know that certain types of
surgeries are not cost effective so what
this is if it requires a mandate to
level the playing field so that people
have access to all these things all
provided by evidence-based licensed
practitioners then great but in an Ideal
World we don't need that mandate that
people will
recognize that these things have value
and then they should be vited and
they're cost effective and we can
actually maybe decrease cost rather than
increase cost and the next question then
becomes what's the forces that are
causing the status quo and that's a
question I'm not answering here today
but I've asked it and so you know that's
when I I think when we get down to
mandates is like well why aren't you
doing this and and and yeah everybody
has said well we do offer this we do
offer that we do yeah well you do when
you don't and um um you know I can get
back surgery tomorrow you know and even
if I don't need it I can get it and
you'll pay like 100,000 bucks or
whatever to get it that doesn't make any
sense so it doesn't not not only doesn't
make sense it's not cost effective so
the chiropractors have saved our butts
many times the physical th have saved
our butts and saved the insurance
companies a ton of money by taking care
of their shoulder or the elbow whatever
it is with a non-surgical approach right
as we all know you know medicine has
changed dramatically and I would go back
to the mid90s when the rvu system came
out I think that was horrific having
said that it it still is you know the
the carrot that is driving a lot of
people to do surgeries M and when they
could go and have you know something
done
non-surgically without a medication or
maybe just with physical therapy
whatever but what I'm saying is that I I
would try to distill this bill down to
what we truly want to think about as far
as mandating if at all what providers do
and I think they do a lot of it already
yes but also then you know make sure
that you know that is offered to the
patient that's where the patient
centered part becomes very important
that they are now part of the discussion
that acupuncture Physical Therapy Etc is
is part of their treatment modalities
repres can I ask a simple sort of
digressing for a second but I'm going
through and looking at the one that's in
the black not the one that's in the red
um it has on top of it House Bill
554 oh I I'm reading through this and
read through it before but it reminded
me when I look at
line 11 it says we have to try things
before you can prescribe an opiate then
it goes on and talks about nothing
section and so forth you have to exhaust
everything before you can write Opia but
then you go down to line
21 it's a conflict it says nothing in SE
the section so preclude a healthcare
practitioner from simultaneously
prescribing an opiate or prescribing or
recommending any the procedure set forth
in paragraph one so therefore when I
read through it I'm not a Wordsmith here
but if it says here I could WR opiate
anyways then why do we say you have to
do all these things it's kind of a
conflict in there it it was of striking
all that I just trying to understand
yeah from yeah from writing the law we
sort of have built into it a conflict at
least I see it as a conflict but I'm not
an attorney so I'm looking for somebody
who's got more legal than I do I I have
more legal e but I only have the copy of
the large thing with all the red and the
black I don't have the thing that it's
actually right over my colleague to the
right is is working off of what he's
reading from is actually page one and
but I hope that strucken part you will
agree on a particular template to work
off of and and keep the notes on one I
would like to work off the the one with
the red and the
black yes well I mean that's in there
it's just
struck
right so this is now the one we're not
working on so what we did was we took
the original Bill and this is where the
the challenge becomes is we took the
original Bill and then we put together a
multi-stakeholder ad hoc group right and
then we rewrote it and and what's what's
left is I kept some of that let's just
go back to First Things yeah we have
pieces of paper in front of us yeah this
is the original bill it's all in black
yeah this is the other thing that I was
given which is some black and some red
and it's very thick and it's bit cross
off but it's not
what um has just been referenced by
several of the last few speakers which
is a completely different document and
I'm just hoping that instead of talking
about page two on this
document uh I mean pick one stick with
it and get it to the point my my
intention of this discussion is that the
only Bill that we're only piece that
we're dealing with is with the one with
the struck stuff and and not struck
stuff and certainly you're welcome to un
strike stuff but that's what we're
working from does that make sense no I
just I just want to know of these two
documents which one you're using I'm
using the one with the red and the black
uh they both have little bits of red and
little bits of black this is one with
editing on
it and this is one that is
read the one I sent you is actually the
same thing it is it's just
format that was one that I sent out in a
Word document to all the members of the
yeah got it I'm
just but what representative Merchant
reference yeah what represent a merchant
repres reference was the the bill that
was stuck in front of us today that's
from thank you for that
clarification I didn't realize when I
sent it to you would come out
differently easy read yeah Mr
chairman yes
represent McDonald to representative
Murphy's Point uh obviously this is a
complicated issue and we've we're trying
to even we're getting a little confused
here but if I may reference another bill
we just experienced um that came over
from the from the other body uh sb44 40
uh that whole optomologist optometrist
thing much of the problem with that was
so complicated so confusing their
objectives weren't even clear uh and I
sat in numerous meetings about that
we've got to make this very as
straightforward as possible if we're
going to be successful and the simpler
it's got obviously got to address
everything properly but it's got to be
as straightforward as possible if we're
going to be successful in getting this
passed I think the other thing that
confused me a lot CU When we we created
a bill that was like a page long and
then all of the sudden it goes into to
be written up and it comes back a
million pages long with references to
multiple places and statute and that
makes this even more confusing because
basically all it is is one section
struck in two things that are
functionally the same thing but written
two or three different times and and so
it probably would be helpful to just
on page three starting with line 13 and
that's the thing that that's the gist of
everything up to page four line 31
that's the entire gist of the entire
bill but it's repeated twice does that
make sense because it totally confused
me even this morning when I was
reviewing it it totally confused me but
that that is what what the new section
of the bill
is um one of the re one of the other
reasons cuz representative um lungren
did an awesome job at doing this and
bringing it to our attention and forcing
and pursuing the issue further the
problem was is getting multi-stakeholder
support so you know that's kind of how
we got to where we are right now taking
what you started putting it into this
format and that was what was able to get
multistakeholder support and then with
the insurance company's in uh input is
how we got to the licensed element of it
so why we limited it to licensed people
the number things that we argued about
or discussed about it that we still are
open you know to question on their part
I'm sure is you know the number of
treatments you should provide for each
of these things may versus shall you
know that kind of thing because we had
that that was a huge discussion like
should this be May or shall um um um you
know and those are things that are in
this bill in fact I have it in there may
or shall one's in parenthesis one's not
because that's that's an important
discussion Point um one of the other
issues is that they they claim that they
already provide these services um this
gets and then the other little Minor
Detail this only applies to 22% of the
insurance industry which is a huge
problem anyways so I just want to make
my two cents about the May versus sh I
assume that they may do all of these
things right now and and as you just
said um many of them are doing some of
them already so if you're going to have
a bill um saying that they may do it is
not actually doing anything um uh but
but certainly sh is is going to set
people off and make it much more
difficult but um my concern is always
that we often have bills that are
described as feel-good bills where we
say you know somebody might be doing
something well that's great uh but
people are either already doing them
they they're already not so um if if if
you're actually going to have a bill it
probably ought to be a sh that that was
my opinion as well and I appreciate that
statement feelgood's nice but it doesn't
accomplish
anything
um talking about the insurance companies
develop some way is double double ways
there what I'm trying to think through
with the committee here if it's truly
patient centered is how do we somehow
protect the insurance company from
Financial
Risk because a lot of times it comes
down to is you're trying to measure
and monitor if you will the risk you're
taken on financially because you have ex
number of dollars coming in a premium
and how you spend it out and so forth
you have to be cognitive of what you're
doing on the expense side instead of
trying to get into which I don't like
his mandates is allow either the
provider or the patient to have back to
like with hospice there's some guard
rails Financial guard rails on it so
that it just can't run a muck um but
there's also more leeway within it so
the patient at that point in time has
along with the provider has a little
more say in how the resources get
utilized but the insurance companies
protected from outside of the guard
rails so there is some sort of way to
minimize the financial downside but
allow for the patient provider to have
more flexibility and utilizing the
resource themselves represent
th
um so I mean most of the things that are
listed now are not hugely expensive like
um not that physical therapy is cheap
but compared to surgery it's cheap um I
guess one thing might be that and and
there I guess for negoti is whether it's
12 visits or whatever it's going to be
for a given thing so then the the issue
about how it might get out of hand would
be if you have five different options
here does a given patient get 12
treatments of all five different options
or or is there some other limit that
kicks in after you've tried but the flip
side if it's patient centered if they
tried physical therapy and that didn't
work shouldn't they be allowed to try
acupuncture if I can answer that because
I want to just explain how we got to
where we are so the original bill um
actually basically said it wasn't a sky
the limit thing but it listed a number
of different entities within each
subcategory and The Way It Was Written
is there were 20 visits not 12 and that
person could have 20 visits of every one
of those things and when you did the
final number it was like over a hundred
I mean it's a lot and so you know the
insurers appropriately pointed out that
problem and and and then then the next
number question was like when I and it's
nothing against chiropractors when I
first started out like you know I've
been here for almost 40 years but in the
beginning you know we'd have patients
going three times a week for decades and
and the insurers are paying for that so
is that excessive as well the number 12
was basically a compromise and you could
use 12 from each of those four
categories what's really important when
we talk about pain is and centered
integrative care is my favorite example
is that when a little kid hurts
themselves you know Falls gets a boo boo
the first thing the mother does is come
gives the person a hug then kisses the
Boo Boo and then begins to do range of
motion they've now done three different
modalities for one acute problem and
that's the way we treat things so that
you know if you know acupuncture and
Chiropractic together may be a good
thing to do together and that's why it
was important that you not limit 12
allog together you know that you could
do 12 of this 12 of that so they could
work together that that's where the all
these numbers came from why we did it
that way um and the 12 was a compromise
because 20 would have been preferable
but
nice one more thing U just thank you
back to what representative Murphy
talked about which was the that the that
the um that the the insurers will Pro
will ensure an adequate number of
providers I mean I mean that I guess I
guess you would you wouldn't you would
want to make sure that they I'm sorry
you didn't get to talk I wanted to have
you guys
talk oh can you be convinced to stay a
minute thank you
anything I just wanted to thank you
kept you're
welcome um sorry so well just about that
because I mean if you said um that an
insurer will in will ensure the
appropriate number of primary care
providers I I'd go like Well everybody's
trying to do that and nobody's
succeeding um so I
just I guess I'd like a little
perspective on that because I guess
there needs to be something that that
says well we're going to pay for it but
but we don't have any any acupuncturist
on our on our preferred list so
essentially I don't know I'm really glad
you brought that up because you guys are
bringing up all the questions that I had
without me having to bring them up so I
I personally would strike that um it was
it was what was the uspf wanted it us P
Foundation wanted that language in there
um in Massachusetts it may be doable in
New Hampshire it's probably not um so um
um I I I thanks for bringing that
up thank you Mr chairman um oh sorry
representative Murphy um just a couple
points with while it was a lull here I
wasn't sure I understood should when we
get to shall and may I understand but
should threw me way
off should you know so that was one of
the questions I had the other one I had
was you know if you do multimodal and
you want to put a definition in there
and you put synergistic or complimentary
effect it may be good to put in their
alternative effect as well and the
reason I say that is because Behavioral
Health interventions is entirely
different than manual interventions so
you know they may not be synergestic but
they may be alternative so I just add
that as a suggestion not necessarily to
words Smith it over liso but I just add
say that one more time like I want to
make sure I understand what you just
said I I would I would add in
multimodal it talks about synergistic or
complimentary effect I would also say
and also
alternative got and the reason being is
because behavioral is different than
manual therapy of different sorts you
guys are like the best you're waste this
is fun so are we replacing should with
shall or may or both shall I mean it's a
waste of time to do this bill if it's
not shall right but rent Murphy where
where are you which page uh again I'm
working for um the r one the one that
31 it's interesting because um and I and
I I I want to um just emphasize is that
everything that I try to do in healthc
care when I'm running symposiums or
whatever is that we always include a
patient at least one because last I
checked they're the smartest people when
it has to do with their own body and um
that terminology and that came from
patients not from us so that's why
that's important but I agree it all
um this is a lot of information and
um I mean you've pointed out all M oh
sorry did you want to because I I'm
trying to think of like where we go from
here um this is a lot to throw at
everybody here at one time I I I didn't
intend this to be a last step today
um I don't know how you all feel about
that but um um this is a lot of
information good for stuff for me and
it's virtually everything you brought up
is stuff that I was thought about or
concerned about so I I can I I would
suggest that we do go forward I'm sorry
that we've given you so much information
no no it's what I want basically managed
um but if I had two things in my mind
that would and I'm thinking about as
representative McDonald mentioned you
know if we when we get to the point
where there'll be a vote on the floor
someplace or in a committee somewhere
it's going to be very important that we
address the responsibility of the
provider and also their education and
their recertification and their
education that's already done and what
they do
already uh but also to make sure that
the insurers are part of the equation
and you know in my most simplistic terms
is is that if a
licensed non- quack you know provider
offers an alternative to opioids then
the insurance coverage should be there
to make sure that it's covered that
would be my simplest and I that' be my
one page summary document in the last
five days I've been called all sorts of
names um um yes yes and and in my
medical career I have been referred to
as a quack at times I started doing
epidurals in 1987 for back pain because
I thought it had value and I know
prominent doctor in this state referred
to me as a quack who 30 years later I
actually did an epidural on so I always
struggle with the definition of quack
but yeah I get where you're going yeah
mostly I was saying the non- quack you
know that the the people that provide
the healthcare do the appropriate thing
refes what and I'm just going to remind
every body here that this is a very
productive
discussion but when we get to what we do
as a committee sometime between now and
October 20th the only thing we will be
voting on is recommended for further
action or not recommended for further
action so if all of the word smithing is
not
done uh that's okay I always think it's
helpful to have sub committee meetings
where they're open to the public people
can come people can listen and um you
know sometimes it's not pretty but it
it's helpful in terms of input and
openness of the process but if if the
words are not completely smithed by the
time the committee meets that's fine and
of course going forward uh the chair can
certainly appoint whatever ad hoc sub
committee the chair thinks is valuable
and
useful um
always remembering that all of our
Personnel is going to change on December
5th so you just segwayed very nicely
into what I wanted to ask all of you
about because everybody here has more
experience than me but when we did our
prior authorization bill which I was
told had zero chance of passing it was a
waste of my time um and I said well it's
important one of the things that we did
that I think guaranteed its
success was that we put together an ad
hoc group that included um and I think
these are very similar issues that's why
I think that you can superimpose them
but the group included this the hospital
Association the medical society um the
two sponsors which are me and Senator
rardy uh the insurance commission
um and the insurers and we sat down at a
table as equals and hashed out this bill
what makes sense what doesn't make sense
this needs to get done how do we do it
and how can everybody be as happy as
possible one of the the reason I wanted
to direct it this way at this time is I
really think that needs to happen for
this bill to be successful because I'll
be honest if we eliminate the insurers
from the discussion this isn't going
anywhere and that's a waste of time and
that process can happen in one of two
ways one of which is that uh you and
other private citizens can meet with
anybody you want to meet with at anytime
with any without any notice to anybody
you don't want to notice but including
everybody you want to include and that's
just a private meeting and that's no
problem if it is an actual subcommittee
as this is appointed by our chair then
we are subject to the right to know law
and the notice requirements so there is
nothing that stops a group of interested
people from meeting as many times as
they wish to meet and discussing Ways
and Means and seeing if they can come to
uh a consensus which then gets filed
with OS either in November or as a uh an
amendment to a bill filed in November
thing we did do is for re strategic
reasons we actually put the bill in
through the Senate so that would give us
more time anyway if we chose to do that
direction
if I could follow on
that if it's a private meeting at that
point in time can that be done
online virtual versus being if it's a
private meeting it's a a meeting of
private citizens and they can do
whatever they want to do if if it's a
meeting that is a house meeting we have
to do it in accordance with our house
rules and with RSA 91a so I from the
insurers and the audience I I think
Larry you were there right
were you there at that meeting that we
did for prior o no was oh Andrew I know
you weren't yeah I just I don't remember
I'm pretty sure it was a noticed meeting
but I could be wrong but it was held you
know at the at the State House well
we've had we've had a number of
different forums uh for a uh one could
be a statutory study committee yeah uh
which is created in chapter law and and
Al those often bring together
multi-
um many different people wearing many
different hats this is a retained Bill
committee so the only people who can be
on the actual committee are uh house
members but you can of course listen to
anybody you want to listen to um so it's
possible that it was any number of these
things but there have also been any
number of very good bills brought to us
that have been the subject of lot of
meetings outside of the legislative
process by people who are interested and
who are stakeholders who are trying to
come up with something which has a
chance of of getting through because
they have sat down and discussed it uh
carefully before they started and and so
there's there's Merit in all of those so
um because this is what my where my oh
I'm sorry represent so I have more of a
question than anything else at this
point and maybe the insurers can help me
with this as well if you have and I'm
I'm trying to get at the heart of the
bill which is really to as you mentioned
from the
outset as a response to the opioid
crisis that we had and we still have
going forward um if you have a licensed
certified credential privileged
provider I didn't say anything about
quackery but if we have a provider that
offers an alternative to
opioids has that been
uh denied by the insurance
carriers and the reason I asked that is
because again it it gets to the point
that if I provide a service and I choose
not to do surgery but I provide
something I think would be very
effective for the management of that
patient outside of the surgical realm or
the
opioid uh medications have they been
denied so the the question the reason I
asked that question is that if you have
the right
person providing the right
Alternatives has that been then denied
by insurance carriers and therefore the
Genesis of the problem that we have
right now so that's why that's it's
almost a rhetorical question but that's
the part that I want to get at in the
bill that should not be arguable well
what's been interesting historically and
you and I have been around a while and
um but when I first got here um you know
Chiropractic Care was off the charge I
mean all my a lot of our patients were
going every you know couple times a week
if I remember right and um and now it's
like Feast to famine and and that's what
a lot of the chiropractors and that's
why this bill came from them um a lot of
the other entities it's really
interesting because the minute you
accept Insurance you accept everything
that comes with it like prior
authorization and all the headaches and
all that kind of stuff so a lot of the
the groups that I work with they don't
do with a bill like this cuz they're
very happy living feif for service at
low cost so um um but yeah I mean
massage isn't covered by almost any and
we know it has benefit um um
Chiropractic is covered by most insures
but it's very limited um compared to
what it used to be um acupuncture to me
is almost a joke I mean like CMS
approved it for chronic low back pain
which is the one thing it's least likely
to help I mean it you know it's like
well yeah we acupuncture no you don't
you cover it for something that it's not
going to help um and CBT has always been
really challenging like you know mental
health interventions and things like
that and we know for especially for
chronic pain CBT has a cognitive
behavioral therapy has a lot of value um
and getting access to that is really
hard so um and be honest it's a lot
cheaper than a lot of these
anti-inflammatories
are yeah yeah I wasn't even going to go
that far so to answer your question yes
that was the Genesis of this is people
don't have access to these things um you
know and and some of them that that was
the one that always bothered me is like
I made a a deal with um an insur a long
time ago about
acupuncture basically the only patients
that they allowed me to treat were
people that exhausted everything first
and I said the most like the patient I
most likely to help is the patient I see
before it begins to be a problem not way
down the road you basically just
you know guaranteed that I'm not going
to help any of your patients and and
then you're going to conclude I'm
useless when if I had done it here not
there and that that was the other thing
is timing is critical it's you know you
don't want to do these things it's like
anything you don't want to do it too
late you want to do it earlier so so
timing is important and access is
important well I'm glad you brought the
point about timing because you know you
get into a chronic pain
situation and no matter what you do for
that patient it's not going to be
helpful whereas if you were to take care
of that problem right from the get-go
with the appropriate therapy that may be
very helpful and that includes you know
therapy it's interesting because if the
national pain strategy was one of the
greatest documents ever produced by the
federal government that never led to
anything and it it's not that but
basically what is they put together was
a group and I was kind of involved in it
but you know we came up with six pillars
of pain strategy that we needed to get
on one is early
um um you know was timing with and
prevention prevention of chronic pain
before it starts and if you don't have
access to these things earlier then you
may have a higher instance of chronic
pain which means that you're going to be
stuck with very costly things forever so
prevention is important but it's the one
thing that very difficult to prove it's
successful and at the same point um you
know even in virtually every element of
our health care System prevention is the
one thing we do rotten so um anyways
this is funny I get to babble about
stuff I hate to say this as a surgeon
but I would say that um you know what
we've come to realize is that often
times the the things that we are most
likely to benefit from substantially
Education Health care whatever your
beliefs are about climate change Etc if
you do those today yeah they have
significant impact not 5 years are now
in the election cycle or four years or 2
years but 30 years down the road the
same thing with Healthcare you know so
if you provide that Health Care early on
the insurers would actually see a
benefit financially as
well I yeah
totally so I guess represent lber I just
had one more drafting thing if I may go
off the board because I I was rooting
around in the statute trying to figure
out why we needed to do this twice and
the answer is one is individual and one
is group exactly um but I I do have one
further suggestion which is that in
normal statutory drafting you put your
definitions at the top rather than the
bottom so um when when somebody actually
gets to the point of drafting something
for OS you might make sure that that
goes at the top rather than the bottom
and then uh I leave to them remembering
which is a section and which is a
paragraph in which is a subdivision and
all the rest of that they'll work that
out for you but uh putting it at the top
is is helpful in terms of understanding
what comes behind and it's where people
will look for it so I have a pragmatic
question that's kind of related to that
so this is what I in in if this wasn't a
legislative meeting what I would do at
this point would say you know what we've
discussed this we've given this to you
can you look through the draft tell me
what you think changes need to be made
I'll make the changes and then we meet
again to go over that make sure I got it
right and or we have it right and then
then cuz I have to submit a report I
think in October 20th before October
25th yeah so we have time but I was just
thinking we could meet one more time um
and then come up with a strategy um but
but I I would it might be helpful if
people could do that and then then I'll
try to take there's somebody here from
OS that can correct me if I'm wrong but
my understanding is you're perfect ly
okay with the right to no law for
everybody to send you their thoughts and
you can put them into a draft you need
to then not discuss it back and forth
between everybody on the subcommittee
until you get to your new meeting so uh
everybody can send you their thoughts
and uh you can consolidate them and you
can certainly send that out saying here
in preparation for our meeting on
Thursday is a draft that incl everything
I've been sent but then you have to
refrain from saying oh and we're all
going to as a group right discuss it
back and forth which is entirely
counterintuitive and one of the toughest
things for new legislators to learn
because it's how we all work outside of
the legislative process so if we could
do that I would appreciate that but I
would like to I I mean I don't we have
more time but I would like to schedule
you know another meeting to perhaps
finalize that and get next steps um
um I have another question on pragmatics
so um because I I know when we tried to
do an ad hoc thing with HB 66 we were
told that if there were more than so
many members of the committee present
that it would be functioning illegal
meeting
um so in other words if I we put
together an ad hoc meeting with insurers
and whomever um um you know all
stakeholders they all have to be less
than a quarum right of a legislative
body and so human services so if it's
the Health and Human Services
committee you can have uh you have to
have 10 or less oh we and and but if
you're 10 or under you're home free
because it's a 20 member committee oh
that be and a quorum would be 11 so
you're you're golden so we should okay
so can so this is what I would like to
do going forward if everybody can give
me their feedback on what they saw um
thank you for bringing up that wrong
thing about chiong and whatever um that
was helpful and then we'll make a note
I'll go over this entire document and
then we're having a house meeting on the
10th right and that's more than two
weeks away what day is today I mean
could we meet in like two weeks to um to
finalize that and then next
steps well Mr chairman you were thinking
about having our committee meeting as
opposed to any other meeting uh sometime
the 8th or the
9th which would be the committee meeting
at which we vote either to recommend for
future legislation or not recommend for
future legislation but we can do that in
the absence of actual wording because
that committee doesn't doesn't vote on
the wording they just vote on the
concept so here's a motion oh go ahead
sorry yeah to representative Weber's
Point chin I were discussing
earlier I believe it's 13 interim study
bills and we need to get them out before
October 25th we're thinking having a
work session and an executive session um
on you know the two days before uh veto
day which is October 10th and um you
know trying to dispose of all of those
okay so um but if talking two weeks out
from today that would still be September
that'd be like the 27th or something um
two weeks from today is the 26 26 26
so
uh do we is there a date that has been
select between October 8th and October
9th well we're looking at October 8th um
if that works for for the members of the
committee it's a little bit off topic
for 554 but um if October 88th works so
you folks no representative King it
doesn't
work I have a conference both the 8th
and the 9th oh okay I'm working that
week so that
not
okay I'll be out of town I I'll be back
on the 9th I can't do the e but I can do
the actually
no I'll be I'm like representative King
I'll be out of town that
week and again it's it's not going to be
like normal executive session it's not
going to you know the bill isn't going
to go to the floor or anything so it's
it's not a huge I'm not saying it's un
important but it's not as as Paramount
as as other executive sessions would be
because we either recommend for future
legislation or not and even if we don't
recommend they can still be brought up
so so all right so I guess we may have
to go to the ninth from what I'm hearing
I don't
know and and again we can adjourn by
three and call another meeting you know
following week who because I I I am
respectful of the fact you have another
meeting at 3 so so even though I'm not
invited to
it so it's safe to assume I don't want
to assume I'm not going to assume um are
we in agreement that something will come
out of this
legislatively yes all right so um I mean
that's all you needed to know correct
from us well as I understand it um the
interim study committee report uh and
that does need to be one even if it's as
simple to say not recommended for future
legislation the more we can put into
that the more of a head start it gives
the the bill next time okay and given
the challenges and I don't know the
history of this bill as well as some of
you do but sounds like it's faced a lot
of challenges in previous efforts and
the more of a head start we can give the
bill next time in the next session Yeah
the more likely it will'll have success
so to answer more we can put into that
in study report for the next okay and
the next effort I think the more the
better it'll be to get it some of um
represented Merchants concerns earlier
on there was virtually the original Bill
had virtually no stakeholder support
even the groups that it was designed to
help didn't support it and so that was
the Genesis of 303 was to actually well
how do we actually get stakeholder
support
and so um how would that been in other
states we have virtually no other state
model to go by except Massachusetts and
the outcome of that wasn't that great so
um we tried all along to include the
insurers in the in the discussions um so
you know and I understand their concerns
I get it totally um um but that was the
Genesis what we got in front of us now
is this is what we had got stakeholder
support for so virtually every
stakeholder supports what we're
proposing except maybe the insurers and
so the next question is like how can we
work with them and and I also with that
said you know we're you know this is my
world this is the way I think but every
insurer in this state is you're the best
people on the planet you guys are wicked
awesome you're the best people ever
we're not necessarily legislating for
you but we're NE we are legislating for
other insurers that may migrate into the
state date and as I think um and again I
I will reiterate what I've said before
is that there's a concerning Trend that
in the next 5 to 10 years there will be
four to five providers of Health Care
and four to five insurers for the entire
country and if we don't get control of
that
now they will dictate to us when they
get here and and and that's really
important to me because I mean the death
of Private Practice is the absolute
worst thing that's happened to healthare
opinion I just also want to plant the
seed in people's minds that it's very
likely that a newly drafted bill will go
to Commerce yeah rather than to Health
and Human Services because they do the
insurance pieces so as you are
considering who to talk to Talking to
folks on the Commerce Committee and
making sure that they are involved in
the process is going to be key to
success I actually already reached out
to some certain person that you know who
I'm talking about um to talk about it we
apparent did not connect I think this
little thing called an election probably
got in the way but but yeah I did reach
out to him to talk to him about it um um
and I think he would applaud the the
concept of trying to bring everybody
together to do this CU it won't work
otherwise I'm not sure who the
individual is but if the same one I'm
thinking of I'm sorry it's
representative hunt I should be compl OB
I suspected as much he hasn't been too
sympathetic to this bill previously but
making inroads that's great for whatever
it's worth I wasn't either but I saw the
Merit in the concept but the bill itself
was great greatly flawed and so you know
when I found out the chiropractors and
support it either is like oh my God so
like all right it's a good concept how
do we fix it so then I just brought in
people wasart than me and we just sat
down and tried to figure out how to make
it better and it still was greatly
flawed so um but I think what you got in
front of you is better than what we had
work again the simpler the more
straightforward the better I think so a
37 oh yeah a 39 page cannabis bill is
that's too short
right we got when when we were p passed
our prior authorization Bill the CMS U
proposed the reforms within 3 days of us
going to the Senate and our bill was
about six pages long their reform
package was 850 pages long so um and I
thought eight pages was too
questions this was wonderful um I never
asked asked anybody from the public for
add I don't have anything to say I just
wanted the definition of chronic pain
yep and how about the last four words
lasting more than three months we got
rid of that yeah I mean the reason why
was we're not just talking about chronic
pain so we're talking about pain in
general because you know all these
modalities can be used at any part of
the treatment process so it didn't seem
to make sense sense to me to
differentiate for the purposes of this
bill the other work we're doing as you
know um that you're very involved and we
differentiation I think unless anybody
has anything else represent Merchant is
it possible to receive
a document that is not red and black but
just black so I can look at
try to get confused between what I'm
trying to ignore and what I'm supposed
to pay attention to help me immensely
thank you how about this now that I know
all of you are involved I will send a a
unredacted copy to all of
you I'll apologize for having gate
crashed because no it was you were
really
helpful yeah no nobody should ever
apologize I mean representative King was
probably the most helpful cuz I kept
looking at she was going hm what's he
thinking and like oh my God Mr chairman
so the copy that you're going to be
sending out next will be all black but
all the redacted stuff won't be in there
at all right correct okay unless you hit
markup I guess right send something that
is drafted the way legislative services
does it start with the language that's
there in the statute cross out anything
that's in the statute that you don't
want to continue on okay but how about
if I send you two separate copies one
that's totally as you requested and then
it's it's up to you I mean it just I
think for a lot of people they're used
to reading the way os does it yeah and
they start with the statute they cross
out anything that's going yeah and then
anything that's new is bold and vitalic
and that way you can see what is
completely new and the thing that's
always complicated that is if it's a
whole section that's staying that it
stays in in regular print you don't
realize that it isn't new until somebody
tells you but um it's just easier that
because what I sent you and I'm not
going to rear organize like you said
definitions I'm just going to leave it
where it is for now but um but yeah that
is what I sent you was what I wanted to
leave and what I wanted to
stay language that you want and leave
somebody else to deal with statuto stuff
and just so we emphasize it's not a me
thing this bill was actually worked on
by about seven or eight people you know
who do this work locally regionally and
nationally so this this wasn't just a me
striking this or striking that we we did
it as a group so and this was an adock
group and this was done like at least
three three or four years ago so it
wasn't recent but because this bill is
this is Bill the same exact bill was
presented three different times so my
what I'm hearing so clear about this
I'll receive
a document you'll take all the stuff out
as redacted if you areu that just stri
stricken Y and all I'll have at that
point in time is a clean document I do
understand where represent where is
coming from but once we're trying to get
back our comments you're going to colate
all those comments eventually and they
we'll come back and talk about the
comments collectively is that where
we're going sequentially and then once
that's done that will go on to OS and
they'll take the document and go through
the process to strike out what's being
removed out of the law and then bold
italic size if you will that's being
added so is that the sequence I'm trying
to get through well the OS might be like
a step further at this point but I would
I don't think we need to worry about OS
at this point exactly exactly you'll
have to worry about OS November During
the period from the day after the
election when things open to whatever
the date is that it closes cuz that is
our only window of op opportunity in the
house there is a larger window of
opportunity in the Senate and that may
be the reason for doing it through the
Senate but you can't just say in January
we're going to go to the rules committee
and have them bring it in because uh the
rules committee has always said if you
knew you could have brought it in in
November and didn't sorry wait for next
year so so just to get even farther with
that I mean the purpose of this inter
study committee was basically to say
this bill has value we're going forward
the next step is one of us has to write
a bill and that'll probably be me or
David or whomever representative L Gren
or whomever but like um I'm just there's
a space there is just going through the
house side of the Senate side I I
haven't decided that yet um I can see
good reasons to go both way either way
um um I actually reached out to a
senator friend to talk about this today
too sing Senator B so we made chairman
of HHS we may want to bring her in then
that that's exactly the direction I was
thinking of going partially one of the
reasons why I mean it was so much easier
to do like when you guys weren't there
but like the you were there right Heidi
when we did the thing on the prior Roth
we had that yeah the big meeting because
I thought that was helpful right so um
because that's I don't know if you were
here when I said that but that's what I
wanted to do with this and um but to do
it through the Senate it like you know I
mean Senator rardy just told her
secretary and the whole thing was
arranged you know I mean it was just
pragmatically a lot easier and and then
the committee it got assigned to was a
lot more proactive and we were able to
make amendments to the bill that you
know in the process that allowed us to
get it through the house because I think
if we goone out the house first it would
have died so and in the end I think
everybody's better off so I might do it
that way
not so all we need to yep
yeah
yes
twins because if on
1:00 not 1:00 I have
I
e
hey good afternoon everybody and welcome
to um the uh work session for the
subcommittee on S
sp495 um which is relative to the
certification of Alcohol and Other Drug
use treatment facilities so welcome and
before we begin just like everybody to
stand and representative king would you
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all all right
thanks
so so um I I do believe on the table
there was a uh a copy of the agenda and
basically um this is just a rough
guideline of some questions that I had
in my mind over the summer um our our
former committee researcher did some
research so I would kind of like to
begin the hearing kind of going through
um and you know and soliciting any
feedback uh from uh members of the
committee or any of you folks um if you
would like to you know kind of make
comment on uh what we're doing in in
other states and and and how we kind of
compare here
also you can feel free uh when we met in
June everybody just kind of moved up to
to the main table if you think you're
going to have a lot to offer rather than
having everybody just coming up to to to
the witness box as it were um if if we
get into a discussion feel free to to
migrate up and and and fill in the empty
seats just so that we can kind of keep
things moving um we are going to lose
representative Weber relatively early so
uh what I want to do is kind of get in
right away into looking at some of the
work that the uh Community researcher
did and uh with with some difference to
getting some of her questions answered
before she has to leave so yes
representative
King uh before we go too far I my main
question is what's the purpose of this
bill I I believe the background behind
this was that somebody had abused a
client at a a an agency or not an agency
but uh a reform house or whatever um and
this bill is trying to do what to uh
alleviate that in the future so my
understanding uh from the testimony and
from what we talked about uh when we had
the the initial meeting in the fall and
everybody else can feel free to speak up
there's a couple of issues certainly um
one of the things that was offered in
testimony was they brought up the nhpr
uh podcast the 13 steps where there was
an abuse of of somebody that was going
in for treatment and so you know what
can we do to to mitigate that but in
addition to that um
also when when people come and they're
going to get treatment how effective is
the actual treatment itself so this was
not just uh I don't believe to look at
addressing the abuse issue but also
making sure that when you have an
opportunity to get somebody into
treatment that you know we we put some
guidelines in place that that treatment
is going to be as effective as possible
some of the feedback that we got from
folks in HHS as well is you know they're
trying to kind of understand the
landscape of of substance abuse
treatment and so um it's my
understanding that if the facility is uh
getting Medicare or Medicaid then
they're they're kind of bound by that
rules they're registered by the
department but you know if you're a
nonprofit or a for-profit and you are uh
basically not taking Medicade then
you're kind of off the radar so there
were a couple of different irons in the
fire that that that this bill was trying
to to get to so anybody else have any
additional thoughts on that
representative
Weber well I'll defer to representative
Shapiro on this because he's one of the
potential uh revisions that we had um in
in the copy of the bill that you handed
out to us I believe limited the
facilities to outpatient facilities
because we found in committee that there
were so many different kinds of
facilities that it
was it's not a one-sized fits-all in any
case and I think that my recollection is
that what the committee then hung up on
was the issue that that uh folks
practitioners who are providing services
are licensed or certified to do whatever
it is that they are doing for a service
and the question among committee members
and I'm remembering this coming
particularly from representative
Merchant was as long as the providers
are
certified why is it necessary to certify
the facility as well and the committee
is a committee had to plow old ground
had reviewed the issue of sober homes in
the context of um them being places that
were unregulated and therefore that that
was brought to us as a concern by the
Fire EMS folks that the conditions in
which people were living were simply
unsafe uh but I think that there is
concern
that facilities that are completely
unregulated may not be dealing with
people in an appropriate Manner and I
think the question for us or for me at
least um is if it's an
outpatient facility where people are
seeing licensed
practitioners I am a lot more
comfortable not having a certification
on the actual facility than I would be
if people were living there but um I
think one of the things that the um
hearings pointed up was the depths of my
ignorance of the whole subject and so I
I'm certainly keeping an open mind and
can be persuaded either
way but I just wanted to be sure that we
understood that the bill is that we're
looking at as it is now is just
outpatient facilities and that may be
the way we want to go we may want to do
something else but yeah and that is
correct
because there is a separate bill looking
at Silber homes representative
supero yes I I think when the bill first
got introduced to us there was a lot of
confusing things in it and um and it it
turns out that residential programs were
not included in this and that's where
the alleged abuse happened and they are
already have some kind of oversight by
um the
department um so I think at our
committee we I mean I probably not
accepted by everyone but I think fairly
broadly um accepted that services that
are provided to New Hampshire citizens
should have um healthc care um Services
should have some kind of oversight by
the state um whether that's strict or
not so strict um I think that's broadly
accepted and I think um this bill was
brought because there's a certain um
group of programs that that don't have
any oversight and I think we got into at
our committee we got into a a
discussion about facilities meaning like
buildings um or lenses like a licensed
clinicians and I think
um it is true that licensed clinicians
already have oversight through the
whatever board their Li Ed by um but I
think some of these outpatient programs
are not just and
and I am certainly not an expert on this
either but certain of these programs
these although they're called outpatient
programs they're not necessarily only
individual counseling programs so um
they may have people who are working at
these programs who are not licensed so
did not fall under the board of lers one
of the boards
and I I think we're not talking about um
oversight over
facilities or lies as much as um
programs um you know kind of like having
some kind of oversight
of whether a program is effective
whether there's U misconduct where
somebody can go when there's misconduct
and so that's the other part of the bill
is to have an
ombudsman um to um follow follow up on
complaints
um I don't know if that clarifies
anything yeah I think it doesn't and I
and I've had a lot of conversations over
uh the summertime with a lot of folks
who are skeptical about the bill and it
all comes back to the whole oplc versus
DHHS um approach which is why where
where I'd like to kind of mine a little
bit deeper um I did notice um if we go
through a and we look at um the the the
work that uh Miss Dyer did over the
summer time where she was comparing
different states so I'm going looking at
appendix C I'm looking at a state like
California where they are going in and
they're going after the folks um who are
you know the service providers as well
as the facilities themselves but then I
go and I look at a state like Florida
where unless it's dealing with something
related to the Department of Corrections
they're just licensing uh the the
providers so it seems like there's a
Divergence there there's not Universal
consistency there and so um thinking you
know because a lot of the push backs
just to share with everybody that I got
back is why not just go the oplc
am I say yeah the oplc route and have if
everybody is a certified provider um and
we're not talking residential care
anymore that's outside of the purview of
this bill would that not be adequate and
so with that in mind go I go back to
appendix a no sorry yeah appendix uh B
sorry that uh was done over the summer
and if you look the only thing I see
that you know is a Certified Recovery
support worker and a licensed clinical
supervisor and a licensed alcohol drug
counselor uh
so it looks like when I'm looking at
appendix B I have all of these things
that exist already um so I guess the
question I would have for you folks is
even those facilities that you know
operate outside of the realm of Medicaid
and
Medicare the folks that are employed
that they still have to meet these
criteria am I correct or not correct
don't think so you don't think so okay
so so I so I wonder um since we have
appendix a
types types types of substance used
treatment in New Hampshire um um if this
is
indeed accurate I wonder if we could
have someone from the Department go
through these and say which ones of
these um we're trying to address with
this bill and do they in and those that
we're trying to address do they in fact
only have
all
right so hi there I'm Jenny O Higgins
I'm the legislative liaison for
Behavioral Health with DJ Jess welcome
thank you so if we're looking at
appendix a and we're looking at program
type here um what you're looking at is
actually the different levels of care
under the Asam and so high-intensity
residential and low intensity
residential would both be
licensed right by our Bureau of
Licensing and so they they are regulated
under the 826 rules of DHHS partial
hospitalization is considered outpatient
and so that would fall under the spill
I'm looking at everyone's nodding with
me so that's a good sign um an
outpatient an intensive outpatient would
all fall under this bill medic patient
assisted uh treatment it can be at any
level of care so medications for
substance use disorder could be could be
happening within inpatient and
outpatient
settings um or through your primary care
so that's
really across the
outpatient recovery groups would not
fall under certification or ler nor
would recovery community centers or
recovery housing those would not fall
under this bill no right okay so
recovery community
centers and Recovery housing the
department does help with help fund and
help with quality oversight and
everything of some of the R's programs
um and there is a certification process
in place for Recovery housing but those
would be separate from this outpatient
so my next question
is so those would be the kinds of
facilities and programs that this bill
would address the ones that you just
highlighted so going into the B appendix
then uh am I in the right one yes so
going into the B
appendix
um it looks like like a licensed alcohol
drug counselor these are all currently
licensed with
oplc yes so when we were looking at the
types of or levels of care you're
talking about licensing or certification
through DHHS these are individuals with
a license through oplc okay and
regulated by oplc so it's sort of two
layers so and just let me ask one more
question represent shap leget so um are
are there so is are there any gaps in
this list
relative to the the kinds of services
that are being offered so I'm looking at
this looks like a pretty comprehensive
list of like a recovery worker you just
can't be a recover a certified you just
can't be a recovery support worker you
have to be certified you can't just be a
clinical supervisor you already have to
be certified so those certifications
already
exist are there any gaps in the
staff that you know you can think of so
it's not this well I'm sorry I did
misspeak earlier when I said oversight
is listed in this um chart and I had
said they were all overseen by oplc but
you'll see on here Board of Pharmacy or
or the Bureau of drug and alcohol
Services listed so I just want to
correct that first because I I just
broadly said oplc but there's a couple
different layers of oversight so
Certified Recovery support workers are
certified under Bas um but it's not the
bill is not so much addressing a
staffing issue as the outp patient care
right and so and that and so the LIC
those who are licensed and working
within that outpatient care that that
regulation already comes under oplc but
there isn't the quality of care
oversight in the outpatient space
besides those who are contracted with
the Department
today hi I'm Sarah Cleveland I work for
the Bureau of drug and alcohol services
so the programs that we're talking about
are partial
hospitalization outpatient and int and
intensive
outpatient and the individuals within
those services are licensed or certified
but it's the program itself so it's like
going to a doctor's office and your
physician is licensed but maybe the
entire practice isn't and if the
individual staff members are not doing
something that rises to the level of uh
that could be investigated or a
complaint but then there's nothing you
can do to in terms of oversight if it's
a broad spectrum problem over entire
organization right now in outpatient we
anything representative Shapiro so first
question is it so we're talking about
three three of these categories three
but two of them uh medication assist to
treatment and ambulatory can happen at
any level of care so they can happen in
but we're not talking about those
specifically right now so first question
is are there might there be people who
work in these programs who are not
licensed
yes at what kind of level is it office
staff or is it um is it some kind of
doing some kind of clinical or support
work not clinical work but maybe support
work people working toward their
crsw but haven't gotten it yet um a lot
of times people who are working toward
their CR who don't actually start
working toward their crsw till they've
been working there for a while or don't
want to work toward their crsw because
of the time and expensive crsw Certified
Recovery support worker thank you um so
okay so there are some unlicensed people
in these programs and
um but like I said if if nothing that an
individual is doing arises to um a level
that you can bring to a board if it's
just a broad organiz
ational incompetence right can be could
you give
us make up an example or um like what
would be kind of a broader type of
dysfunction or a broader type of
misconduct or a broader type of
inefficiency of services that might not
might not come under the umbrella of the
licensing board but be be a more Pro
programmatic problem can you give an
example yeah sure size of a group would
be an example that comes to mind right
so like the an appropriate size of um a
recovery support like group group being
held by by a clinician though so that
type of service would be in our rulle
making today for those nine agencies
that we are able to have oversight over
so the amount of um people in a group
relative to the facilitators of the
clinicians okay following best practice
in terms of treatment using
evidence-based practices that's nothing
that the um oplc is going to investigate
but as if it's the culture within an
agency then that would be something that
um as a former clinician myself I'm I
always like um concerned when people use
the term evidence-based practices
because people just use it but they
never talk about what the evidence is
but but if there was if there was a
practice using a model being used that's
a discredited model um that would be an
example right um I mean there have been
groups through the history of substance
use this order programs that are maybe
cultish that kind of thing um so if it
was a discredited model or model that
there were concerns about it being
harmful that would come under this
versus
um maybe the licensing board maybe both
but okay representative Weber yeah that
that was kind of my follow on is I I
would assume that under most conditions
it probably wouldn't be an either or but
if am I right in thinking that one of
the issues might be that you could bring
an action against a particular clinician
for that clinician's actions but even
and and remembering that those are quite
cumbersome uh that it then then you've
dealt with that clinician but there are
many other clinicians who might come and
continue the program that is still
similarly discredited and and may I just
put you entirely on the spot and say are
you is the department in favor of this
legislation at least in concept or
taking no position or
um if you don't want to take a position
that's fine I'm just trying to figure
out P we're all on conceptually in favor
would not be able to implement it
without staff so there's there is
language in the existing bill that says
with subject to funding yes and I I
appreciate that distinction we hear
about that all the time and to run an
outpatient treatment center you don't to
own one you don't have to be licensed or
certified so if an owner is saying You
must follow x y and z when doing
treatment well you can get rid of
individual practitioners but if that's
still continuing right there's nothing
that can be done it's also the
individual the intimidation of an
individual in a very vulnerable state
and how do we bring forward potential
allegations of misconduct and so the
idea of making sure that the programs
fall under the existing Department wide
on busman's office right what could
potentially be a critical place for
people to report if we were if those
things were well posted and and
education were available to make sure
that people knew how to come forward
right today it's a pretty intimidating
process to try to uh name a clinician
well may I have a followup yes and and I
I now have small amount of Greater
knowledge because in the course of
another volunteer job that I have I've
now encount encountered the partial
hospitalization program
and uh am aware now that I wasn't before
of how very intensive that kind of a
program is so you know to me there's a
great difference between something that
somebody's going to a couple of hours
one afternoon a week and my
understanding is that these are often
full day programs 5 days a week and and
very intensive in terms of therapy so um
it it um
those two things make a huge difference
in my mind and I think I I'll just speak
for myself conceptually um I think it's
very important frankly to have some kind
of oversight to the program as well as
the uh certification I mean and I I come
from a background as an attorney you
can't own a law practice unless you are
an
attorney um
so you know you are you the owners are
subject to attorney discipline from
moment one or at least that's the way it
was when I was practicing it may have
changed but um the the concern I have is
the global organization that comes and
and and you know they're the employer
they get to say what they're going to do
and people have the choice well I'm
going to quit and go somewhere else but
uh
I also know the number of people who are
motivated to
enter this area of care want to help
people and and so they're probably not
going to be quite so much okay my way or
the highway is as they would be if they
were working in retail and could go to
another
store um so I certainly conceptually am
very much on the side of the department
Department ought to have some oversight
over the
program as well as the oplc having the
oversight over individual clinicians
because I think that there there two
different possibilities you you can have
one bad apple and that's obviously can
be taken care of by oplc but it's the
overall
culture and the vulnerability of the
people in the
program by definition
that to
me really means that we need to know
what's going on there are also a lot of
out of state um companies that have
started programs in the state that we
don't know about because they don't get
insurance through Medicaid they don't
get any
oversight and their owners may be from
Florida California
and we don't know who they are can't get
in touch with them don't know what
so um and and I'm kind of leaning you
know as you are towards some oversight
on the programs um and I've had some
discussions about that but on the other
hand I do want to push back because
there are other folks that push back on
me and you know when we talk about for
example the use of we don't want to have
people using discredited practices and
we agree but sometimes that can be uh
you know maybe a catchall which may
stifle Innovation and so some of the
push back you know that I'm getting when
I'm because I'm trying to talk to gauge
support from a diverse crowd they're
saying is you know when you talk about
discredited practices are we going to be
potentially stifling some Innovation
here whatever so the utsman portion of
the bill is there um so if you get into
a situation where you have you know a
clinician is taking on too many people
or they're really engaged in some
practices that are really really out
there um is that adequate or um do you
do you feel that there are deficiencies
within that that know even with the
edsman we still would like to have the
program oversight so I just would like
to these programs would not fall under
the EMB budsman unless the certification
was in existence so the edsman covers
Department programs but today the way
that this the the way the RSA um reads
is that the department can certify those
um substance use providers in with whom
they're in contract with which is nine
of providers in the state today that
were in contract with throughout patient
services but we know there to be 65
providers registered with Medicaid with
over a 100 locations and that's only
those that take Medicaid so the
landscape of services that exists
outside of whom we already oversee it
would be those nine providers that the
um budsman could uh take complaints and
investigate right now without the
certification if someone who was going
to a facility that we had no oversight
of went to the um budsman they wouldn't
be able to do anything so let me just
ask a follow-up question out of complete
ignorance so recently we brought into
place a right to know Ombudsman um
and would it would it be possible
or is yeah is it possible to maybe
modify um the I guess the terms of the
armman so redefine what the aitman is
able to do and not able to do so as as
it is currently laid out the aitman can
only do what you say it can only go
through you know that which is uh
certified licensed by the department um
is is a better approach to basically
broaden that portfolio um or do you
think even if it could be broadened to
look after this we would still need to
have the oversight of the
department I think that we they wouldn't
what what would they be investigating
without the rules under certification so
if the um budsman goes out to uh follow
up after a complaint but there is no
certification of those programs it's
oplc or if it's a clinician within the
program that's one thing because you can
go to oplc but it's sort of that or
nothing if they're not licensed or
certified so I think the EMB budsman
would need to be investigating a breach
of something in
Rule and I would also add that the udman
it relies on complaints and this is an
extremely vulnerable population who is
in uh excuse me sorry Jamie Powers I'm
the CEO for Life Services for Recovery
which includes Gate House treatment
which is one of the outpatient programs
that would be um fall under this
legislation and you the folks that we're
dealing with are they're scared they
don't necessarily know what is okay and
what is not okay so the likelihood of
them raising a complaint is fairly low
whereas a more proactive
certification gives people an idea of
who's out there what's right and allows
the department to have a set of
standards that are not currently in
place so just to just to clarify them
from my own mind and kind of say back
what I think you're saying the armman
could go in if we expanded this the role
without these rules he could say you are
a bad practitioner I can take action on
you but uh if you're seeing 25 patients
or whatever best practices I can't
really get after for the for the
facility the the current today um
budsman oversees the Departments
programs so that means only the nine
that are contracted with the Bureau of
drug and alcohol services in terms of
substance use treatment and that means
that they that what the EMB budsman
would investigate is a breach of the
rule under our RSA 172 and so that's
where that's where that investigation
would sort of take place if it were a
clinical piece it would still go to oplc
okay thank you that's very helpful you
had a question representative we well
I'm kind of exploring the questions that
you had a little further because you
were talking about the right to know
Ombudsman but I'm wondering if
um a more apt parallel would be to be
the office of the child advocate
and they
are given much broader investigatory
Powers than your um budsman that we're
referring to here half where it's a very
specific and very narrow um purview and
so there there are two things that I'm
thinking about first of all uh do we
simply expand the power of the Ombudsman
to inquire
into the treatment of vulnerable
people receiving
treatment on the one hand and do we do
the whole rule making process on the
other I mean my understanding is that um
you know when when the office of the
child advocate went to Tennessee and saw
the conditions under which uh kids who
were theoretically
being treated
were basically incarcerated and also
subject to various forms of complete
humiliation
um it it it seemed to me to there there
may have been actual rules that were
broken there but it seems to me that it
was a broader inquiry into the welfare
of a vulnerable
population so I guess my question both
for you and for the committee is what a
good step first step if if i' prefer to
have all of this but if we can't and one
of the things I'm thinking about is what
we have heard about budget constraints
going forward would it be possible to
Simply um broaden
the Mandate or the
permissible I I it's more permissive
than
mandate um of the
existing utsman to investigate
programs that don't fall under their
mandate
now I just go back to what would they be
held what standard would they be held to
without the ru making of the
certification so you wouldn't be able to
say sort of your group is too large back
to other example the per the ratio of
clinician to to um folks with in
treatment is too large because that is
is n written anywhere or it's written in
rule for those who are contracted with
us but if you're not contracted with us
even if the um budsman is expanded I
don't know what standard you're holding
they don't have any requirement I'm a
private business owner and that person
would come to my business and say I want
to investigate you I'd say under What
whose authority right okay fair
enough thank you for that representative
Shapiro I'm I apologize but I didn't
catch your name but I did catch that
you're a CEO of some kind of program
that falls under
this Jamie Powers I'm the CEO for Gate
House treatment in nsha and Gate House
treatment has which of these types of
program partial hospitalization and
intensive outpatient uh with mat okay so
can I ask you um the question
referencing um comments that
representative mlan made before about um
stifling Innovation or um being I don't
know maybe another way to put it is
being overly prescriptive about what
kinds models of treatment are used and
what kind aren't used so would you have
concerns about that if if this kind of
bill went into effect I I would not and
the reason for that is i' I've been in
the field in New Hampshire for close to
20 years now and the model we've always
used is evidence-based practices and
that because the definition of that is
somewhat Broad and it includes sort
promising
practices that we've seen a great deal
of innovation over the years and
sometimes that innovation has become
part of our system and sometimes we've
realized maybe it was not our best plan
ever and we've backed away from it but
there's never been a case that I am
aware of where by being contracted or um
a Medicaid provider I felt that we were
unable to innovate our care in our Care
thank you and innovation in this field
is so needed and it's we're always
looking for new things new that are um
productive and that really help clients
we're really trying to move in that
direction yeah so I I just kind of want
to hammer that point home so so you
you're contracted with Medicaid and
you're finding no stifling of innovation
and these rules that we would be
bringing forth if this legislation was
to pass would be going in that same
direction so basically the same
basically it's going to be in the same
Lane I'm not going to be adding in extra
things over what would be for the folks
that are um it would be very similar
very similar okay thank
you sorry Weber and I'm just going to
reiterate one of the uh points that I
think I made at the earlier meeting
which was that um not only is innovation
important but I
think it seems to me without any kind of
formal training in this it's kind of
axiomatic to me that the the kinds of
treatments that might be effective for
me might not at all be effective for
somebody else even though we have an
addiction that may look very
similar um our life experiences are our
body
chemistry uh the amount of trauma that
we have undergone for one reason or
another and the types May dictate very
very different
treatments and so I I too I want to be
sure that we're not either stifling
Innovation or uh limiting to any one
school of thought because it seems to me
that we
need the the more we provide a wide
range of things that are useful to at
least a certain segment of our
population we're we're better off we're
we're serving people better one issue
the field has had has actually
been having the same type of treatment
for every single client within a program
which is completely antithetical to the
direction the field is moving in it's
moving toward very individualized
treatment but that's not really
something you could complain to oplc
about if you're using an evidence-based
practice it's just not appropriate for
um this particular client well it's my
clinical opinion that it is well it's my
clinical opinion that it isn't and there
would be no way to really parse that out
um so we're really trying to have ways
to have oversight of things that are
still allowing for that
individualization of care okay hi
Michelle Meritt I'm the president and
CEO at new futures um so we were're
working on this bill my colleague Jake
has been the primary policy lead but he
is at a national conference this week so
I'm pinch hitting um the only point that
I wanted to make is part of this
conversation because it did come up a
little bit is that there is a difference
between the lure and certification of
programs and individual counselors and
also what insurance is going to cover um
so programs May innovate and they may
have you know really Advanced practices
but there's no guarantee in any case
that insurance or Medicaid are even
going to cover it in the first place
that may be something that is entirely
self-pay um but it would not be stifled
by virtue of what we are trying to do in
this piece of legislation they are two
separate issues entirely what insurance
is covering and what they're not
covering so for example best practice
would not necessarily be everyone in a
28-day treatment program however we know
that that's how Insurance works we also
know that they do prior authorizations
and utilization review on a schedule
that does not match what the clinical
indication is of a substance use
disorder and put that onus on the
providers to continuously redo them so
we're talking about two sort of
different things and I just want to make
sure that we're acknowledging that if
there are things that are stifling
Innovation it is not by virtue of lens
share and certification that's happening
information so I think with that we're
going to lose representative Weber soon
but I
think so we talked a lot about oplc
versus HHS we talked about you know do
we go the the utsman or not and I think
we cleared up a lot of that we can maybe
let it stew in our minds a little bit
and come back to it when we meet again
but I would like to then you know having
let's say we're going to go forward with
this path you know where the HHS is
going to
certify um we really went in with some
of the amended language which I think
came from New futures um I think I
handed out the amendment where we
basically had cut everything down we got
rid of the shall include but not limited
to um so I just want to if everybody's
okay just kind of look at these and you
know make sure that within the scope of
what we talked about earlier um this is
what we want to cover
um do we take stuff out do we put stuff
in is it too comprehensive or not
comprehensive enough so um I'd like to
kind of open that up and did you want to
say something yeah I'll just add that at
the time in which new Futures was
supporting um committee members around
an amendment for this particular piece
of
legislation even what you see before you
was not the ideal that we had wanted to
put forward it was really to try to get
a compromise that we could get something
done this session because there was
urgency in regulating these programs and
we were Hearing in real time about
individuals who were being harmed by
programs that that DHS had no ability to
regulate um my suggestion would be that
The Advocates and others get together
with DHHS and we take another look at
the entirety of the bill and potentially
even overhaul it so that we are directly
addressing the set of issues that we've
described here um
and can I representative and and I'm I'm
just going
to I'm comfortable with what I have in
front of me which has several layers of
revisions um I think I think that
starting with something that uh both
people
running the programs and the department
think is workable is a very good idea um
but I'm going to remind people that at
least on the house side the windows of
opportunity are very narrow and coming
at us very quickly um and you know we
will only have that window of
opportunity in
November um the Senate side there's a
little more wiggle room but um you know
I I just want to make sure we all have
that in our minds as we're yeah we've
been working in Partnership Department
of Health and Human Services through the
entirety of this so um I have no I guess
hesitation at all or um concerns that we
would not be able to come up with
something that is mutually agreed upon
so so Mr chairman could I make a
suggestion which is yeah um my
suggestion just because of the most
immediate thing um I believe that our
chair is thinking about uh a meeting of
our full committee the week that is the
veto day week which is coming at us very
quickly um my suggestion was perhaps
that we make a motion that this be
recommended for further
legislation and then we can certainly go
on working on it from now till
whenever um and and maybe try and nail
down some of the specifics but um
if if we at a minimum as a
subcommittee recommend it for further
legislation that takes care of that one
deadline we can talk to the committee
about the lines along which we are
thinking and I I think to me it sounds
like what we have here is sort of a
floor and then maybe there are other
things that um people would prefer would
like to see in there as well and I don't
know whether that's one bill or two
bills but it seems to me it gives us a
lot to talk about going forward and
whether it's filed as one bill or two
bills is is for more
discussion I I I was unaware that he was
looking to do that on the 10th um so I
hear what you're saying it's actually
the 8th or the 9th the 8th or the 9th
yeah so so however because the 10th is
feed her day however I would like to
because my my intention here is to have
somebody hopefully who is going to get
reelected from the subcommittee put in
the language and I would like to have as
much information to be able to vet that
language when we come back on the 8th or
the 9th and if I develop that language
after that time we have something that
we're comfortable with but we're not
going to have the opportunity to test it
until the new year and I because we we
got we have very different opinions
those of you who were around for the
original hearings uh in the spring and
so I really want to come back with as
much of a direction as possible to to
understand those folks that had concerns
how far have we gone to addressing those
concerns So when you say you folks are
close I mean how close are we if I was
to I'm going away next week on holiday
but I'll be back the following week
would would would that give you enough
time to be able to say hey I have
something that we could bring
back do you think well I'm just going to
point out that the the the committee
will not vote on the full language the
committee only votes on recommend for
further legislation or not so it doesn't
matter as much as far as I'm concerned
concerned that we actually have the
language sitting in front of us because
that's not what we vote on as a
committee at this point I I but I
understand that wanting the concept and
also wanting to address certain of the
issues that we know are going to come up
particularly the issue of is this going
to stifle Innovation is this going to
prevent people from trying new things or
to emphasize a particular kind of
program with a particular sort of client
um those are things that I feel more
comfortable about having discuss them
even if I don't have the specifics in
front of me um and and um I I
think it's it's just a matter of the
time frame and what we get when but um
it's it's not going to be the job of the
committee on whatever day the committee
meets as a full committee to Wordsmith a
a a full Amendment or or a new bill I I
I agree with that I was just hoping to
have as as much of a vision as possible
you know for the committee well I I mean
I'll just do a quick straw P the
committee members do do you think it's
worth it to come back again before that
because I do believe I'm comfortable I
have enough information to recommend um
for future leg legislation I I think we
talked through uh the questions about
the Innovation the fact that you know
we're migrating in the areas that are
covered by Medicaid makes me feel very
confident and this legislation is going
to be closely mirroring that um so a lot
of those things are there so I'm
comfortable um but I I'll just do a
quick straw pull of you folks do you
think there's value in coming back one
more time before we go back to the whole
committee or what are your thoughts um
I'm not going to give you my thoughts on
okay you don't need a mic
Joe first thing is that um in in this
amended by the Senate bill that we have
um I didn't read it through before so I
maybe I'm missing it but and I'm sorry
Joe I'm going to interrupt because I I
do actually have to be on a meeting at
to um I think it would be very
productive to come back but I'm out of
time because I'm going to be gone for
two weeks starting in um I'm gone from
the 20th to the
5th um just so you know uh but that
doesn't mean you can't meet without me
I'm certainly my my vote is in favor of
recommend that we recommend to the full
committee recommend for future
legislation but with that I'm going to
have to run and I beg your pardon for
the interruption that's your vote okay
thank you very much good luck so I'm
just going to say that um I'm not sure
you know you mentioned that in terms of
actually um being able to implement this
there would be certain cost to the
department and I'm not sure that those
are represented in here in any way so I
think that's something
that eventually when a new bill is
brought forward should be clearly
represented we did submit a detailed
fiscal note on this bill last session
and so we have those costs at our
fingertips if you'd like us to send them
to the committee the the Amendment uh
included subject to available funding
which then made it somewhat fiscal
neutral but it's not it's just whether
or not we have the funding okay I'm not
I'm not running so I'm not going to be
here but I just think that that's one of
the missing pieces I I'm in favor of
voting
um for um recommend I'm in favor of
recommending that this bill um comes
forward in the next session
um and I don't I don't personally feel
the need to come again to kind of work
on the details of it um I think in the
original
session it was so cloudy somehow um that
people were asking well does this mean
we're going to
regulate um Alcoholics Anonymous for
instance and I think that um more than
changing anything I think we've well as
well as changing some things we've
become clear on what this bill would do
and what it wouldn't do so I feel
comfortable in recommending it for
um being reintroduced and having people
who were very involved in it continue to
work on
that so
um I think we lost representative Weber
um so I think um do do do we with a
subcommittee of five if we want to take
a vote to recommend for interim study to
take that to the whole committee do we
need to make that decision here or can
we have that discussion when we go into
the uh the committee as a whole in
October I think we make it in the
committee not here okay I I think I mean
we can do something informal here but I
think it so representative King what are
your
thoughts so uh to to answer your last
question before I go on to my thoughts
um I'm I'm not
uh an expert on how committees run but I
think there was four of us here that
were and are in favor of moving forward
with this with uh representative Weber
making her thoughts known before she
left so I think we have and besides that
three out of five I think makes it quum
anyway so so are you then of the same
opinion that you you you know what you
need to know um from from what I've
heard this is a little different than
what I've understood before and this it
makes sense I I'm I'm with
representative Shapiro that we really
need to be clear on what we're
regulating I think that was the big
problem we had back in the spring when
we heard this bill was uh you know uh
are we going to have people just uh
taking over and trying to control things
and um um and from what I heard today
that's not the case so I'm I'm in favor
of moving forward the other
clarification that I need is uh is the
language that is being written is this
coming from
DHHS it's my understanding it's being
DHHS been working in conjunction with
new Futures on it so okay so um just
before we move on we have the the
chairman of the Comm committee as a
whole and so you when we planning to get
everybody together to take up these
interim study bills Mr
chair um I I conferred with
representative Weber the ranking member
of our committee uh we're tentatively
looking at October 9th right now
um
um I'm I'm meeting with staff this
afternoon to see we have 13 interim
study bills
and um seeing if there's any interest in
any other subcommittees there's only
been two real subcommittees one one
Function One met this morning and this
one and um so right now we're looking at
at least one meeting occurring on
October 9th I know there's another
meeting that afternoon if we don't get
through everything then then um and I'll
have we'll have a subsequent meeting
everything has to be wrapped up before
October 25th on interum study
reports so thanks to that so I think
with that being said um if it's okay
with the rest of the committee we'll
we'll go forward when when the
committee's a whole meets will'll come
in we'll recommend um but um with that
in mind uh would it be
possible to get that newly amended
language within that timeline because I
I would like to have an opportunity to
review it to send it out to the other
members of the subcommittee um so at
least you know even if we're not getting
back together they've had a chance to
look at it so how's that timeline work
for you yeah new Futures has a really
good working relationship with DHHS so
I'm sure within that time frame we can
get together and come up with some
Amendment language um and get that back
to
you so with that being said does anybody
have anything else they want to add
representative King yeah for the for the
minutes I wanted to put what date that
was going to be is that
October uh 8th the full committee
meeting or the deadline for inter
study uh and again what I'm probably
going to do is send an email to the
committee we do need to make sure we're
going to have a quorum on that dat about
October 9th is the date I'm looking at
okay probably a 9:30 start date and U I
know there's a democratic caucus at 3
that day so we' try to wrap up by 2:30
if not before so people can ideally grab
some lunch
and if we're making slow progress we'll
probably have to adjourn and continue
everything to another day but my thought
it was would the notice would probably
read a full committee work session and
subsequent executive session on all
bills that that would be the goal and um
and again as representative Weber has
pointed out earlier today and I don't
know if she did at this
meeting the only thing the full
committee is going to be able to do is
either recommend for future legislation
or not recommend uh none of this is
going to go to the floor this point it's
going to have to come forward as a new
bill in the next uh next term so so yeah
October 9th and then the ultimate
deadline for all interterm study is
October
25th thank you is so is that everything
that you need then you're all set um
here's the tricky one who who moved it
it with there was some discussion when
you were out of the room about whether
we take a formal vote here or do we or
do we just bring it to the discuss it
informally and have an informal vote and
then bring it to the full committee yeah
so we're not going to take a vote today
we're we're going to just bring it forth
to the the committee discuss it do we
need someone who um makes a motion and a
second well I think I think for the um
for the committee to consider what what
happened here it would be nice to have a
formal sense of what the committee wants
to do whether you want to do it as a
vote or want to just gauge if there's
any formal objection or whatever it
would be good to know the a a formal
sense of what this committee the
subcommittee wanted to do what wants to
recommend that's right so then I'll make
a recommendation uh for
uh uh submit for future
legislation I'll
second and I think um I think
representative Weber um retroactively
voted for
but but she's not here so let's let's
let's let's keep it legal so um so uh
all in favor say I I opposed good so
with that being said um I just want to
thank everybody for coming out members
of the committee and and you folks like
I said a lot of questions a lot of push
back but I think it's important because
there's a lot of push back from the
folks of the committee as a whole and so
some of the questions we've been
answering I think will go a long way
towards addressing some of those
concerns so I really appreciate
everybody taking the time out to come in
and talk with us and with that um this
hearing is adjourned thank
you thank